before he cashes in on the tragic loss
of American lives and has been Ghazi
movie revisit Michael Bay's attempt to
cash in on the loss of even more
American lives in Pearl Harbor you think
you know the real story of what happened
when the Japanese attacked that fateful
day but you have no idea then it was
actually just a backdrop to a stupid
can't be made up love triangle it's your
nose that hurts
I think it's my heart and a bunch of
wacky slapstick comedy entirely
unacceptable resumed military aircraft
so it hurts some fierce Mead Rafe
McCawley a fighter pilot with a terrible
southern accent I'm a file I'm gonna
take my wings away who falls in love
with Kate Beckinsale and his pal Danny a
fighter pilot with a terrible southern
accent it's not training over the Hertz
War also falls in love with Kate
Beckinsale when a real historical event
gets in the way of their fictional
relationship these two good ol boys will
take to the skies and single-handedly
drive the Japanese out of Pearl Harbor
humph wha okay so you know they were
like actual war heroes who did that
right experienced a Michael Bay fan
fiction version of history that's more
American than two soldiers donating
blood into a coke bottle where all the
men were noble Patriots not anxious to
dies just anxious to matter there's
nothing stronger than the heart of a
volunteer Jack all the women were
naughty nurses he did have a very cute
but would you happen to have any friends
take your pick
and not even polio could stop the
president from getting us some sweet
sweet revenge whoa yeah USA USA hot on
the heels of Titanic's massive success
enjoy a blatant attempt to recreate the
magic coal profits of that far better
movie but with way more explosions and a
bombing sequence so genuinely cool
you'll almost forgive the rest of the
movie for being so terrible oh man here
we go
Hill yeah whoo yeah get out oh wait
sorry
wrong team Tam and Michael Bay why'd you
make that look so cool so strap in for a
three-hour 140 billion dollar film that
cost as much to make as the actual
rebuilding of Pearl Harbor lasts a full
hour longer than the actual attack
managed to offend both us and Japanese
veterans and most tragically of all gave
a Michael Bay movie its first and only
Oscar win for sound design you are just
so so so starring a daredevil pilot
Black Hawk dumb Kate Beckinsale errs
help me help you
ese and racist Porky Pig and not story
these actual heroes of that day Kenneth
Taylor and George Welsh - actual pilot
buddies who shut down six Japanese
aircraft during the attack
Annie Fox the first woman to win the
Purple Heart Alice and Dean Darrow an
actual servicemen and nurse who fell in
love and got married after he was
wounded at Pearl Harbor and literally
anyone else who was at Pearl Harbor
except for Cuba Gooding jr. 'he's
character he was awesome Bora Bora Bora
you guys know it's only a matter of time
before Michael Bay gets his hands on 911
right [ __ ] just got real
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
smokey this is not Nam this is bowling
there are rules hi I'm Paul my name's
blurryface and i care what you think
there's a Starman waiting in the sky
he'd like to come and meet us but he
thinks he'd blow our minds time may
change me but i can't trace time and the
stars look very different today